every Thursday our series a more perfect
union aims to show that what unites us
is far greater than what divides us this
morning
Adriana Diaz shows us how one woman in
Philadelphia is using the power of
solidarity to fight cancer in the Latino
community once a month in the mostly
Latino neighborhood of North
Philadelphia laughter echoes from a
community center where dozens gather
over their shared language learning
culture and a shared adversary because
it's cancer when you hear that you have
cancer it's like physically in your ears
turn off and that's even harder when you
don't speak English well yes info
Damacio to overcome language and
cultural barriers for latino cancer
patients we've got me know on Seguin
social worker model Ave got started a
group that provides English speaking
appointment companions and a support
network that's more of a sisterhood
Familia - so your own sister see it
gives the confidence they don't feel
lonely they they have someone to depend
on
it's called grupo morally V named for
the so called touch me not plant common
in the Caribbean when you touch it it
close up and it looked like is dead but
then after several seconds it open up
again to life para Philadelphia loose
Oquendo who had breast cancer used to
belong to an english-speaking cancer
group no obvious aqui Mika introduced
you didn't always have that chemistry
you felt like you missed out on
information that may have helped you
yeah she says her poor command of
English also made it harder to find the
emotional support she needed to face her
depression me siento como in familia you
feel like you're with family you feel
supported here Marla says that family
grows every meeting we're going to be
talking a lot about poop today which
include lessons to promote health
awareness so let's go
let's not be embarrassed the group
proactively finds women in need
volunteers signed a lien la posada up
for a free mammogram 13 Williams ever
know you'll say she hadn't had one in
seven years that's when I did the biopsy
alina says this is the first time she's
ever cried over her cancer even through
chemo and radiation it was because I'm
Maria and Marta the Union found out that
Union waffle because they spoke to you
that day you're at the health center
she says they've been by her side since
that day at appointments and group
meetings helping her navigate her life's
new course Wow I say to my friend Martha
cada Baja first joined the group as a
volunteer for their 2016 fundraiser but
roughly a year later she was diagnosed
with breast cancer it's emotional
thinking about what you observed them
going through that you're now going
through now in remission
Martha still lives with the lingering
worry it'll come back
she says knowing her adopted sisters
share that fear helps her through it
okay no one got my sympathy those who
know you've never felt alone no God what
do you think of negativism in them you
feel so thankful to have Madeline who
has helped you navigate this whole
process you guys don't mind done you've
been doing this for how long now four
years then I have four and a half years
have you lost any members no do you
think this group has played a role in
that
well let me tell you something when your
time comes it comes no matter how
positive you are we all gonna die
but if you could improve the quality of
life and may people happier and empower
that doesn't have a price and like the
mo DVB plant
it's named after this group thrives
because of its resilience there's a lot
of happiness in this room oh yeah for
CBS this morning
Adriana Diaz
a lot of happiness indeed Marla Vega who
is not a cancer survivor herself is
about to retire from a three-decade
career as a social worker that means she
now has lots of free time to focus on
her efforts with group Oh more evv what
a great it's so much good positive
energy coming out of it yeah you can
feel it coming over through the screen
did you know the data is clear on those
that that the survival rates happiness
rates increase the more friends you have
around you your support group so way to
go yep